This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English.
From BBC Learning English.
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English.
I'm Dan and joining me today is Neil, hi Neil.
Hi there Dan.
You're a married man, Neil.
When you were wed, did your wife change her family name?
Yes she did.
Was that her choice?
Oh yes, yes she didn't like her old name.
So for her it was a win-win.
How about you?
Well my wife wanted to keep her surname
but was forced to a dot mine because that was the law where we got married.
Would you have thought about taking her name?
That's what we're talking about in this 6 Minute English,
a husband taking a wife's name after marriage.
Or that, six related words and our quiz question.
Okay, let's have the question.
In which country has it been forbidden since 1789 for a citizen
to change their name legally even after marriage?
Is it Asia-Pen, be France or sea turkey?
I'm going to go for be France and we'll see if you're right later.
Now traditionally in the UK, when a man and a woman get married,
the woman takes the man's family name and this replaces her maiden name.
A maiden name is the surname a woman had before she was married.
Now this all dates back to the Norman invasion of England back in 1066.
They introduced the idea that when a woman married a man,
she became his property.
Now as a result of this, she took his name.
These days many women elect to keep their maiden name upon marriage
or combine it with their new husbands in some way.
Sometimes by making the name double-barrelled.
A double-barrelled name is two names that are connected by a hyphen,
such as Joan Smith.
However, a growing number of couples in Western culture are doing it differently.
When they get married, the husband elects to take the wife's surname.
In a BBC article about surnames and marriage,
Rory dear love, formerly Rory Cook,
talks about why he decided to take his wife's surname.
He said that he wasn't really attached to his name anyway,
to him it didn't make any difference.
Well, he's not alone.
A recent study of 2,000 UK adults by Appinium,
a strategic insight agency,
suggested that one in 10 millennial men,
currently between 18 and 34 years old, fall into this category.
Charlie Shaw, a Tibetan Buddhist meditation instructor
who took his wife's name when they married last year,
said that it was an opportunity to acknowledge the unseen patriarchal bias
and sexism in our society.
Patriarchal means controlled by men,
and a bias is the unfair support or opposition to a person, thing or idea.
Many traditional societies were patriarchal,
but modern UK society is less like that.
Everyone is meant to be equal.
Ah yes, but that's the unseen part.
And there's the social view of things too.
Rachel Robnet, a researcher at the University of Nevada,
surveyed a number of people in the US and UK
and found that the husbands of women who keep their maiden names
are viewed as feminine, while the women are believed to
wear the trousers.
If you wear the trousers in a relationship,
it means you have the control and make the decisions for both people.
I wondered about that, so I went out into London and asked people
what they thought about a man who took his wife's name when they got married.
Here's what they said.
I don't think it's a bad idea.
Oh, my dad's 55 and he took my mother's surname.
If people want to do it, then all the power to them.
I must think it's each to their own, really.
Yeah, it doesn't hurt anybody, and it's no different from when we're taking a man's name.
The only reason I think that anybody should take someone else's surname
is just for like the creation of a family unit,
but if it's just out of principle, they don't agree.
It seems that the people I talk to are comfortable with the idea.
Yes, most said that people are free to do what they want.
One woman even mentioned the creation of a family unit.
A unit is a group of people living or working together.
A typical family unit would be two parents and some children.
Well, that answers that question.
People don't seem to mind who takes whose name?
Speaking of questions, how about our quiz question?
I asked you in which country it has been forbidden since 1789
for a citizen to change their name legally even after marriage.
A. Japan, B. France, or C. Turkey.
And I said B. France.
And you were spot on as usual, Neil.
Let's take a look at the vocabulary, shall we?
First, we had maiden name.
This is a woman's family name before she is married.
My mother refused to give up her maiden name to my father when she got married.
Then we had double-barreled.
A double-barreled name is two names that are joined by a hyphen.
Can you think of any famous examples?
Well, there's the Duchess of Cornwall, Camilla Parker-Boles for one.
She's married to Prince Charles, next in line to the English throne.
Then we had patriarchal.
If something is patriarchal, it is controlled by men.
The feminine equivalent is matriarchal controlled by women.
Then we had bias.
A bias is unfair support or opposition to a person thing or idea.
Many fans are biased in favor of their football team.
Then we had where the trousers.
If you wear the trousers, you have the control and make the decisions for both people.
Do you wear the trousers in your marriage, Neil?
Oh, we both wear the trousers in my marriage.
Thank you, Dan.
Then we had unit.
A unit is a group of people living or working together,
like the BBC Learning English team or unit.
And that's the end of this six-minute English.
Don't forget to check out our Facebook, Twitter, Instagram and YouTube pages
and we'll see you next time.
Bye.
Six-minute English.
From BBCLearningEnglish.com.